alors vous l'avez compris si personne ne
s'attend une révolution c'est tout de
même une page de l'histoire du pays qui
se tournent tous les cubains qui ont
aujourd'hui moins de 50 ans n'ont pas
connu d'autres présidents que fidel
castro l'homme a résisté aussi à tous
les assauts tous les embargos au risque
d'enfermer son idéal révolutionnaire
dans ce qu'il faut bien appeler
aujourd'hui une dictature
philippe rochot jusqu'au dernier jour
fidel castro a voulu régler avec son
frère hines les détails de cette
élection qui marque son départ l'homme
qui se retire aujourd'hui peut se vanter
d'avoir tenu tête à l'amérique pendant
un demi siècle avec à ses côtés des
combattants aussi illustres que che
guevara mais fidel castro comme au temps
de sa splendeur reste secrétaire général
du parti communiste pour ses anciens
compagnons de lutte
il est loin d'être un homme fini
quittera jamais la révolution ni meubles
pouvoir il renonce simplement sa
fonction comme le che l'avait il va
continuer de se battre pour ses idées
comme un soldat
si la patrie si son frère raul remporte
les élections fidel castro pèsera encore
sur la vie politique
voilà quarante neuf ans que les deux
frères marchent main dans la main
quarante neuf ans que raul castro
ministre de la défense
on les a vus dans ces grandes parades
communiste l'un aime les slogans
révolutionnaires l'autre raul est un
pragmatique mais une page se tourne pour
fidel castro le monde retiendra les
temps forts de la déchéance ne saigne
homme de 81 ans elle commence avec son
malaise dans un discours de cinq heures
elle continue avec une chute qui va le
clou et pour trois mois dans un fauteuil
roulant
elles se poursuivent avec son opération
de l'intestin qui l'obligent à rester à
l'hôpital
c'est là qu'il a voté ce matin pour son
frère raul bien sûr